1 million two hundred and six thousand
four hundred and five tests for
coronavirus have now been carried out in
the UK including 76 thousand four
hundred and ninety-six yesterday overall
one hundred and eighty six thousand five
hundred and ninety-nine people have
tested positive that's an increase of
four thousand three hundred and thirty
nine cases since yesterday fourteen
thousand two hundred and forty eight
people are currently being treated in
hospital for coronavirus compared to
fourteen thousand six hundred and ninety
five yesterday sadly of those who have
tested positive for coronavirus across
all settings twenty eight thousand four
hundred and forty six have died behind
the numbers there's been an increase of
315 deaths since yesterday across all
settings this pandemic has claimed more
than 28,000 lives and each one of them
is precious each one valued each one
irreplaceable the pain of bereavement
and heartbreak is deeply personal but as
a society we are showing care and
compassion across boundaries offering
support and a chance to talk through
grief together and for those
experiencing the first Ramadan without a
loved one this will be a particularly
painful time I send my sincere
condolences to all families who are
grieving as with Christians who could
not celebrate Easter together in church
and the Jewish community whose Passover
rituals were affected by social
distancing our thoughts are with Muslim
neighbors who cannot break their fast
together
I must adapt their religious and
cultural practices because of the crisis
we have all learned to adapt and we must
carry on doing so after the pliner's two
sets out how we will get back to work
later this week his comprehensive plan
will explain how we can get our economy
moving how we can get our children back
to school how we can travel to work more
safely and how we can make life in the
workplace safer but before we can ease
the existing restrictions we must ensure
the government's five tests are met that
the number of cases are falling that
rates are declining that the NHS has
what it needs and that measures are in
place to stop a second peak overwhelming
the NHS are particularly conscious that
those in the front line of our public
services will need clear guidance on
safe working they'll need the right
personal protective equipment and
appropriate access to testing if we have
to make all the progress that we want in
the weeks ahead we're consulting with
employers and unions professionals and
public health experts to establish how
we can ensure that we have the safest
possible working environments and the
Prime Minister will be saying more later
this week on personal protective
equipment for key workers we are
increasing the spread of distribution
and supply from February 25th to May the
second we had delivered over 1.08
billion items of PPE across the health
and social care system within England
and tens of millions more have been
distributed by our colleagues in the
devolved administration's this overall
figure includes 149 million masks 173
million aprons 2 million gallons and 614
of million gloves on the 2nd of May
alone we delivered an additional 20
million items of PPE within England but
there is much more to do and the work
led by Lord Dayton to improve domestic
production of PPE is vital to our
efforts and on testing thanks to the
hard work of so many across the NHS
public health England our pharmaceutical
sector and our universities we have
tested over 200,000 key workers and
their families allowing those who don't
have the virus to go back to work and
protecting those who do we have now of
course extended the criteria for testing
beyond key workers to anyone over 65
displaying symptoms and anyone who has
to travel to get to work and this week
we will be piloting new test track and
trace procedures on the Isle of Wight
with a view to having them in place more
widely later this month all of these
steps will help us to get more people
back to work and help to support the
delivery of our public services and I
want to thank those who've done so much
to maintain the provision of
public services during this crisis our
teachers of what incredibly hard to
perform in educational support to
millions and the government has
committed 100 million pounds to boost
remote learning for those who need it
most
our newly launched oak National Academy
is supplementing all the work done by
schools and teachers by providing 180
video lessons each week and what
particularly came to help vulnerable and
disadvantaged children carry on with
their education during the pandemic
schools continue to receive additional
funding in the form of the pupil premium
for those pupils who must deserve it
worth around 2.4 billion annually and
we've ordered laptops to help
disadvantaged young people who will be
sitting key exams next year we're also
providing laptops and tablets for those
children with social workers and care
leavers to help them stay in touch with
the services they need keeping them safe
and supporting home of learning and if
disadvantaged secretary school pupils
and care leavers who are preparing for
exams do not have internet access
we will provide free routers to get them
connected while schools are closed over
the Easter holidays we were able to
ensure that more than 60% of schools
were open every day with places for both
vulnerable children and those of
critical workers and the free school
meal voucher scheme ensure the children
who needed it could continue to access
food despite school closures so far
15500 schools have placed orders for
vouchers of which over 35 million pounds
has been redeemed the latest available
data shows that around 49 thousand of
the children and attendants on April the
24th were classed by schools as
vulnerable more than double the figure
from a week earlier and while this is
going in the right direction we estimate
this still represents only around one in
10 of all children and young people
classified as vulnerable we want to see
this figure go up further and we're
working with local authorities schools
and colleges to provide improved support
to vulnerable young people all this
additional support of course takes time
puts pressure on existing staff and
costs money
that's why we've pledged an additional
1.6 billion pounds to councils across
England to support their essential
frontline services including adult
social care this son takes the funding
given to councils to over 3.2 billion
pounds to help communities through this
crisis we've also deployed military
support to assist the public sector the
coffered support force mobilized by the
mo D is now 20,000 strong today over
3,600 personnel are deployed in support
of 86 separate projects in which
military aid is being given to civil
authorities on a national level they're
helping the Ministry of housing
communities and local government the
Department of Hope Health and Social
Care and also the NHS with planning and
logistics in England Scotland and Wales
on the ground they're helping to build
and to staff the temporary Nightingale
hospitals and to operate both regional
testing centers for coronavirus of which
there are now 49 around the country and
also the mobile testing units that we
are rolling at to date there are 77 off
across the country 156 military planners
are embedded at grassroots level with
our existing local resilience forums
partnerships of emergency services local
authorities the NHS the Environment
Agency and others they're helping to
coordinate and to protect our vital
local services and supplies with the
additional support of senior Whitehall
officials in addition we have to thank
local government for their energetic
work because since the end of March
90% of rough sleepers known to councils
have been made an offer of accommodation
reassuring them about their safety and
the government more widely is also
working hard to support those who have
not been identified as shielded but are
still vulnerable in the coming days
we'll be delivering our one-millionth
parcel of essential food to those at
highest risk across the country up to
two hundred thousand telephone calls a
day are being made to the shielded and
councils are helping to support them in
other ways including organising regular
calls from volunteers to those who are
isolated in our communities the support
put in place by many local organisations
has been inspirational as people step up
to help friends and neighbours and the
government has helped to mobilize
another important life
through the NHS volunteers responders
program over 600,000 people have had
their ID verified and are helping with
the daily errands that make such a
significant difference
collecting shopping making contact as a
human voice on the end of a telephone
and transporting patients and supplies
for the NHS and of course we are all
working with supermarkets to ensure that
a greater number of online delivery
slots are made available to those most
in need in every one of these areas the
government in Westminster has been
working with ministers from the Scottish
government the Welsh Government and the
Northern Ireland Executive this has
helped us to monitor and react to the
path of the virus across the nation's
enabling us to intervene wherever people
are in need at each of these daily press
conferences we've paid tribute to the
compassion and dedication of our key
public sector workers I recognise how
much we all owe to their stoicism and
steadfastness nurses doctors Porter's
cleaners paramedics pharmacists care
home staff prison and police officers
teachers social workers those preparing
and delivering food collecting our
refuse and administering our welfare
system they deserve our gratitude they
deserve our support they are in all our
minds they are the very best of us we
owe them so much and we in government
will do everything we can to support
them during the next phases of our
pandemic response